THE >>> FIRST,L LOOK U
REPUBLICAN GOVR TEXABOTT
A MAKESHIFT ER MIGRANTS FROM E
HAITIANS CNN BEETOLD COULD TOWDS
TOE'YOE TARG ETSING TE
N FORCE
F THE MIGRANTSTHE CAMP TO DWI.
THERE
RETUR
COUNTRIES., LIKE R HAITI, E ALLO
STAY.
BLESSED? UNDER THEGE, MANY OF WU
TRANSPORTED TO U.S. N
PRNG FACILITIES.
>> ENFORCE OURTI
ONLYS OF
TARIAN RELIEF,UTF UNTABILITY.FOE
ILY, AND DHAVE
FO L
>> Reporter: SOME EXPELLEDAITI
BORDER PATRTHIS NONPROFIT REFU
TING TO TROUP'S
DIRECTOR.
>> THI AS AMOUNT,
N WE'VESEEN.
>> RepE WE MET
YOU?D THAT IMMIGRAD IDOUHAT DI
HIM THHE DIDN'APARN
T  CLD DEPORTED.
HIION EW
DID ANYBODY TE WE HAITIANSANSOM
ADDRESS, A F H
COULD CONTACT IN THE UNITED
STS WE
STAY.
CNN HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TOONLUIS'
EVERYO
THE NETOR MANY OF E
MITSA NEARBY GAS STATION
ND TAKE THEM S ACROSS
HE'S GOING TO MIAMI.
BYE, PETER, YOU. HAFRAID OF BEI
HAE  RECENTLY.HA
A HURRY UP AND WINTO AN
.N ADMINISTRATION UPPING
SEVEN A DAYN
NO BLSO NCLUDE VERY SO
BEING PORTED.ME OTHANSITIONRIESF
WE HAVE SEENAND YOU SAW IN
THAT PIECE, THAT T
BEINGELEASED INTO
WE KNOW  NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION IN THSTEE
DAYS, NEAR MIGRANTS HAVE RELEAS
CITIES ITEXAS FO
BY. IMMIIOTHORITIES.A OR US,OI
GREAT WORK IN AS.
THANK YOU.
>>> LET'S TABOS
SHEILA JACKSON LEE FROTEXAS.
SHE THMELAND
SECURITY COMMITTEE.
THANKS FOR J US. CHUCK
SCHUMER CALLEDHE
MIGRANTS A
NTHATEFUL AND
XE
DUE TO THEN FOR SOME MIGRANT
YOU'VE ALSO CALLED FORIDEN
ADMI
POLICY.
DID YOU GET Y ASSURANCES TAY
Y METMIICIALST 'L ACTION ONTHAL
FOHA ME.
WH START FROM POINT
I
THE ATHAT WE HAVE MA CRISIS AT E
BORDERAN HAV2,000 MILES, A
F RDD MOST OF THATR ISL
Y AND ITRA
ATELY.
BUT WHAT HASIS BECAUSE
OF THE TRUMP
AND THE DEMONIZINGUGHOUT GER
TTK TOWARD THE
E T SEEM TO  KNOW HODLE
ISY EAGER TO ADHERT  A IMMIGRAN
A LANDLA
AT IS WHAT SECRETARY
T  TE BOERT , K, MEEWITH A NUMBI
UNDERSTA TT  I
TIONAR DHS SAID THAT THE MEDICR
NO ACCURATE.
AND  IA RELIC OF THE
HERE W WT TO
A MORATORIUM AR SUEN
PERSONNEL, TO INDO ES THAT HAVE
ASTH SURGEIN014,S INHE SG OFE T
AN ASYLUM APONT                W
YOU HAVE ARGEST DEPORTATION IN
YEARS, THADOES NOTITFARANOT THTI
WE SAW TL
SOME CES
ALSOSTAND,AKE,AS
THHOITY HA,
MI NATIO
SECURI TO THE PRESIDENOFAA
TODAY, AND YESTEAYE CAME OUTWIT
AIE
AMERICA IS BACK,UT BACR
WHO?
THE HUMANITAAN CRISIS
ADMINISTRATION OTHUT DISGUSTINGR
IN Y.
DARKESMO A
HISTORY.
YERS AR
THEY ARE OUR A OE  TSIALK CAUCUS
I'M AN OFFICER O
GAR RWOMANS CHOM
BEATTY.
HAIRS ANS OF
THCRAS WEL
HERE'S WHERE WE E. BK
AW, THE INTOLERANTSCENCE OF SLY
F LO THA
AND MAYBE EVEN FEELING
INN SOUL.
REAEPPINGAWAY FROM TH.W, HOWEVE
T THAT, THAT T
BUWI.
E IT VERY CLEAR THHE
THOROUGHLY AND QUICK VIDUALST B.
LREADY
WILL NOT BE ANYWHERE NEAR THATT7
R HAVE SEE
TO BORDEMANY,
MANY TIME TOHAG
TO
BEING BLACK AN
IT MUST BEG WITH AFGHAN THAT A
CENTRAL -- FROM THE NORTRNTRIAI.
>> A LOT OF THE HAITIA CROSSING-
DI'TY FLEE
HAITI THISEAR BECAUAKE OR THE P.
THUTA FO MEN IN
BRAZIL,COSO
O TH
STATES BECAUSEF DETERIORATING E.
DOES THAT CHANGE, DO YOU,
THGE WHICH THE U.S. LD ADMIT TH
THESO THNO
EENC S YTHAT YOU POSED
THSTION.BECAUSE THATY LEGAL
THN SOUTH AND R ATEA
010 EARTHQUA.NY OF OT BECOMS THH
EYT.
I WANT TO GIVE THA
ED I T HAVI A T
THIS TIME.OL
ASSASSINATION, EARTHQU
HEE
A HUMANITARIAN CRISI
THAT THE.
THAVD A PLACE THATLE REFUGEETH
CAN WELCOMTHEM
AND  THINKS IS AN ITN
MINISTRATION TO
TE AND TO BE ABLINDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE NN DETERMINED
NAREAT A
N BE MOV ATSE BUT GIVEN ACCESS O
OTHER
CHILDRACCOMPANIED CHILDRENG TREI
HE PATHWAY FORWARD.WE'VE DONE H
ISLL BE THER AS V01N  BORDER ATY
LLN  AND
CIVIL RIATWE CAN GET IDONE
RA
BEENLLACERSTRONG